closing China's annual Congress in
Beijing president XI Jin Payne called on
the Chinese Communist party to
strengthen the country's economy and
security
we will spare no effort to live up to
the times to our history and to the
people make Our Generations new
contribution of building a strong nation
and realization of national rejuvenation
the military he said must be built into
a great wall of Steel to safeguard
sovereignty and called Hong Kong and
Taiwan Inseparable from China
Sue also underlined the need to boost
Innovation and self-reliance a response
to U.S sanctions blocking beijing's
access to critical Technologies
following the closing ceremony the new
premier held a press conference where he
criticized Western's oppression of
Chinese firms he says Beijing and
Washington need to work together
Lee Chung is tasked with reinvigorating
the slowing economy and achieving this
year's growth Target of five percent
currently our economic output is large
and he has exceeded 120 trading God and
we also face quite a lot of new
challenges to achieve a growth of around
five percent of such a high base figure
is not an easy task and it will require
redoubled efforts
the former Shanghai Chief is credited
with creating a NASDAQ style stock
market for the financial center and
persuading Tesla to build its first
overseas Factory on the city's outskirts
boosting employment and the private
sector are among Lee's top priorities
but he's also known for the
mismanagement of a brutal covid-19
lockdown that paralyzed the city for
weeks
analysts say Lee Chung's loyalty to Xi
Jinping will always Trump his personal
policy preferences while people think a
lot about shifting in positions and so
on and so forth the CCP system
especially under XI I think is
um is tightly managed enough such that
you know the the diplomats the officials
will do what they are told Lee Chung is
just one of several close allies Xi
Jinping has installed in the top ranks
of the Communist party this may mean
more efficiency when it comes to
carrying out his policies but also less
pushback and almost zero opposition when
it comes to his power
Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing